hi there steve kaufman here i'm going to
talk a little bit about something that i
think is very important
in language learning and as usual i'm
pursuing this theme of how we can learn
languages faster and better and so forth
and i'm going to talk about uh of course
my challenge five days to fluency
uh if you've been following my channel
you know that i intend and i'm hoping
that five days uh in prague from the 2nd
to the 6th of october it's not very far
away
that i'm i'm hoping that this period
will
convert a lot of my passive knowledge of
check into active knowledge so i've
spent
a 11 12 no 13 months now
largely listening and reading and
working at link and
more recently talking to tutors
maybe five hours a week
but building up my vocabulary my
familiarity with the language my ability
to read to understand what i listen to
in other words my passive knowledge of
the language and i'm hoping that in five
days there will be a dramatic move that
will activate this knowledge and of
course the advantage of learning this
way is that
uh
sort of listening and reading is
something that you can do quite easily
uh it's a little more difficult to
always have you know an opportunity to
speak
um
you may not live where there are
speakers of the language even if there
are when you don't have much language
you're almost
pestering them
uh by going at them when you don't have
sufficient
you know knowledge or familiar
familiarity with the language i'm a
great believer in in developing your
passive ability in the language but
eventually you want to convert it to
active
uh you know an active ability in the
language
so
why do i think that in five days i'm
going to convert a lot of my passive
knowledge into active knowledge
other than the fact that dr houliganov
of youtube fame said that that was going
to happen and i believe him
but also because
it's been my experience
that one of the major ingredients for
success in language learning is
intensity
intensity density of experience so you
know
despite the fact that i'm very motivated
to learn czech
i simply don't have
12 hours a day to spend with check i
have to go to my office to work today
we're visiting with lumber customers
i have my family life my friends my golf
my hockey
so i'm left with listening while doing
the dishes listening while in the car
and then i try to find an hour or so a
day now that i'm getting keener to go
and and work through texts and link and
save words and phrases saving phrases
observing
uh you know uh how the grammar works and
so forth but it's still largely passive
so
in order to give myself that intensity
of exposure i'm gonna go there and spend
five days now the thing to think about
and i must say this issue of intensity
is something that i first became aware
of when i was learning chinese because i
learned chinese to the level that was
you know the goal in those days was the
advanced level of the british foreign
service exam in mandarin chinese i did
it in essentially nine months
other language learners did it in two
years
my results were at least as good if not
better than most of the other language
learners at that time i felt that
because i went at it very intensively
and studied seven eight hours i would
have three hours a day of class but then
the main thing was to go home and read
and read and read i read so many books
in chinese all these books with
glossaries because i didn't want to be
bothered with the dictionary because
again the dictionary reduces the
intensity the amount of time you spend
looking something up in a traditional
dictionary is time that you're not
spending with the language and i was
always motivated to get
as intensely involved with the language
as possible which even as a student in
hong kong meant primarily listening and
reading because hong kong is not a man
was not in those days a
mandarin-speaking environment but i
recognized that having really worked
hard and crammed my learning into a
short period of time i learned better
and i remember thinking in those days
that that the more intensively you study
your progression improve improves
geometrically so if you study twice as
in twice as short a period of time in
other words twice as many hours the
results are more than twice as good
that's how important i felt in those
days 40 years ago that intensity was to
language learning
and that's why for example
when i studied like with check within a
month of check i had worked my way
through the beginner texts that link
created by our learners within a month
as i checked my record now i had started
reading the newspapers in check online
using link even though there were 50
unknown words but that to me was a very
intense experience and listening to the
uh radio the check radio which has uh
transcripts so i was again immersing
myself
in this intense
language environment of czech and that's
why i personally don't consider video
and movies and songs to be so useful as
a language learning
media as language learning media because
the word density the intensity of the
language learning experience is not as
great as when you read and listen
because in my experience when i read and
listen i have to rely on words i have to
try to imagine what those words mean i
have no pictures to help me and of
course songs tend to more or less repeat
the same limited vocabulary over and
over again so i like a word rich whether
reading or listening a word rich a word
dense environment in order to get
familiar with the language and the more
time that i can put into that the better
i'm going to do and the less i'm
distracted in other words looking things
up in a traditional dictionary or for
that matter trying to read or listen to
grammar explanations which distracts me
takes me away from that language
experience that's another reason for
example why
i don't like doing exercises i have
bought some books for check and there
are lots of exercises answer this
question answer that question i never do
them because i have to start thinking
and i'm thinking and struggling or
they'll ask me what happened in the
exercise or they'll ask me to match this
sentence with that sentence all of that
is not to me a real language experience
the way listening and reading are real
language experiences denser more intense
language experiences that's also why
if you go somewhere to have that rich
language experience you have to have a
certain level
if you go to the place before you have a
sufficient
understanding of the language you can't
take advantage of being there the
experience is not an intense
language experience a lot of it just
flies by you because you don't
understand
i remember with you know my wife who
speaks some spanish a fair amount of
french we were in portugal she has some
familiarity with portuguese but being
there had no impact on her at all uh in
terms of improving her portuguese and
even with me
i remember i went once after having done
a little bit of work with this was
before we had portuguese at length some
living language material that i had gone
through and i went to portugal like i
couldn't even get started because i
didn't understand what people were
saying but then after working at
portuguese
at link and and listening to a lot of
our in the podcast especially the
radio
rtf podcasts out of
portuguese radio then when i went there
and i had a sufficient grass then the
experience became dense it became
intense and so that's why i think
that by going there now i think i have
sufficient i have a sufficient
background in check that i have a chance
now of course a lot will depend on how
intense a language experience i can
create for myself in prague so i have
lined up twice a day lessons with tutors
teachers where we basically talk like
i'm doing now via skype
through link and i get a report after
the discussion with my mistakes which i
then review and so forth and so on
because i want to make sure that i get
enough opportunity to speak the language
i don't want to wander around the city
hoping that i bump into someone who's
willing to talk to me
what other adventures i'm going to find
there i don't know we're going to have
our meet up the first night
maybe i'll i'll if all of the pubs in
the center of the city are full of
foreigners i'll take a bus and go
uh you know to the outskirts and try to
find a pub where checks are discussing
the latest corruption scandal
yeah in the czech republic and i'll
chime in with my two cents worth and
maybe get a conversation that way i will
see it's going to be a mystery to me but
i'm hoping that i can create an intense
language experience an immersion an
intense involvement with the language
that's going to catapult my largely
passive knowledge of the language into
active knowledge so uh what are we today
the 17th or so uh we're basically
two weeks away
so
i'm very much very much looking forward
to
my five days to fluency in prague we
will see what happens
thank you for listening
hi there steve kaufman here i'm going to
talk a little bit about something that i
think is very important
in language learning and as usual i'm
pursuing this theme of how we can learn
languages faster and better and so forth
and i'm going to talk about
of course my challenge five days to
fluency
uh if you've been following my channel
you know that i intend and i'm hoping
that five days uh in prague from the
second to the 6th of october it's not
very far away
that i'm i'm hoping that this period
will
convert a lot of my passive knowledge of
check into active knowledge so i've
spent uh
11 12 no 13 months now
largely listening and reading and
working at link and
more recently talking to tutors
maybe five hours a week
but building up my vocabulary my
familiarity with the language my ability
to read to understand what i listen to
in other words my passive knowledge of
the language and i'm hoping that in five
days there will be a dramatic move that
will activate this knowledge and of
course the advantage of learning this
way is that
sort of listening and reading is
something that you can do quite easily
it's a little more difficult to always
have you know an opportunity to speak
you may not live where there are
speakers of the language even if there
are when you don't have much language
you're almost
pestering them
by going at them when you don't have
sufficient
you know knowledge or familiar
familiarity with the language i'm a
great believer in in developing your
passive ability in the language but
eventually you want to convert it to
active
uh you know an active ability in the
language
so
why do i think that in five days i'm
going to convert a lot of my passive
knowledge into active knowledge
other than the fact that dr houliganov
of youtube fame said that that was going
to happen and i believe him
but also because
it's been my experience
that one of the major ingredients for
success in language learning is
intensity
intensity density of of experience so
uh you know despite the fact that i'm
very motivated to learn czech
uh i simply don't have
12 hours a day to spend with check i
have to go to my office to work today
we're visiting with lumber customers
i have my family life my friends my golf
my hockey
uh so i'm left with listening while
doing the dishes listening while in the
car and then i try to find an hour or so
a day now that i'm getting keener to go
and work through texts and link and save
words and phrases saving phrases
observing
uh you know uh how the grammar works and
so forth but it's still largely passive
so
in order to give myself that intensity
of exposure i'm gonna go there and spend
five days now the thing to think about
and i must say this issue of intensity
is something that i first became aware
of when i was learning chinese because i
learned chinese to the
level that was
you know the goal in those days was the
advanced level of the british foreign
service exam in mandarin chinese i did
it in essentially nine months
other language learners did it in two
years uh my results were at least as
good if not better than most of the
other language learners at that time i
felt that because i went at it very
intensively and studied seven eight
hours like i would have three hours a
day of class but then the main thing was
to go home and read and read and read i
read so many books in chinese always
books with glossaries because i didn't
want to be bothered with the dictionary
because again the dictionary reduces the
intensity the amount of time you spend
looking something up in a traditional
dictionary is time that you're not
spending with the language and i was
always motivated to get as intensely
involved with the language as possible
which even as a student in hong kong
meant primarily listening and reading
because hong kong is not and it was not
in those days a mandarin speaking
environment but i recognized that having
really worked hard and crammed my
learning into a short period of time i
learned better and i remember thinking
in those days that that the more
intensively you study your progression
improve improves geometrically so if you
study twice as
in twice as short a period of time in
other words twice as many hours the
results are more than twice as good
that's how important i felt in those
days 40 years ago that intensity was to
language learning
and that's why for example
when i study like with check within a
month of check i had worked my way
through the beginner texted link created
by our learners within a month as i
checked my record now i had started
reading the newspapers in check online
using link even though there were 50
unknown words but that to me was a very
intense experience and listening to the
uh radio the czech radio which has uh
transcripts so i was again immersing
myself
in this intense
language environment of czech and that's
why i personally don't consider video
and movies and songs to be so useful as
a language learning
media as language learning media because
the word density the intensity of the
language learning experience is not as
great as when you read and listen
because in my experience when i read and
listen i have to rely on words i have to
try to imagine what those words mean i
have no pictures to help me and of
course songs tend to more or less repeat
the same limited vocabulary over and
over again so i like a word rich whether
reading or listening a word rich a word
dense environment in order to get
familiar with the language and the more
time that i can put into that the better
i'm going to do and the less i'm
distracted in other words looking things
up in a traditional dictionary or for
that matter trying to read or listen to
grammar explanations which distracts me
takes me away from that language
experience that's another reason for
example why
i don't like doing exercises i have
bought some books for check and there
are lots of exercises answer this
question answer that question i never do
them because i have to start thinking
and i'm thinking and struggling or
they'll ask me what happened in the
exercise or they'll ask me to match this
sentence with that sentence all of that
is not to me a real language experience
the way listening and reading are real
language experiences denser more intense
language experiences that's also why
if you go somewhere to have that rich
language experience you have to have a
certain level
if you go to the place before you have a
sufficient
understanding of the language you can't
take advantage of being there the
experience is not an intense
language experience a lot of it just
flies by you because you don't
understand
i remember with you know my wife who
speaks some spanish a fair amount of
french we were in portugal she has some
familiarity with portuguese but being
there had no impact on her at all
in terms of improving her portuguese and
even with me
i remember i went once after having done
a little bit of work with this was
before we had portuguese at length some
living language material that i had gone
through and i went to portugal like i
couldn't even get started because i
didn't understand what people were
saying but then after working at
portuguese
uh at link and and listening to a lot of
our in the podcast especially the the
radio
rtf podcasts out of
portuguese radio then when i went there
and i had a sufficient grass then the
experience became dense it became
intense and so that's why i think
that by going there now i think i have
sufficient i have a sufficient
background in check that i have a chance
now of course a lot will depend on how
intense a language experience i can
create for myself in prague so i have
lined up twice a day lessons with
tutors teachers where we basically talk
like i'm doing now via skype
through link and i get a report after
the discussion with my mistakes which i
then review and so forth and so on
because i want to make sure that i get
enough opportunity to speak the language
i don't want to wander around the city
hoping that i bump into someone who's
willing to talk to me
what other adventures i'm going to find
there i don't know we're going to have
our meet up the first night
maybe i'll i'll if all the pubs in the
center of the city are full of
foreigners i'll take a bus and go
uh you know to the outskirts and try to
find a pub where checks are discussing
the latest corruption scandal
yeah in the czech republic and i'll
chime in with my two cents worth and
maybe get a conversation that way i will
see it's going to be a mystery to me but
i'm hoping that i can create an intense
uh
language experience an immersion an
intense involvement with the language
that's going to catapult my largely
passive knowledge of the language into
active knowledge so
what are we today the 17th or so
uh we're basically
two weeks away
so uh i'm very much very much looking
forward to
my five days to fluency in prague we
will see what happens thank you for
listening